during the democrat primary debates joe
biden went out of his way to reassure
suburban voters that he wasn't a bernie
sanders style
socialist why are we the only major
country not to have paid
medical and family leave you want to
make real changes in this country
if you want to create an economy that
works for all you need
to take on wall street you need to take
on the drug companies
and the insurance companies and the
fossil fuel industry you don't take
campaign
contributions from them come on give me
a break
no i will won't give you a break on this
one joe joe you just
contradicted yourself one minute excuse
me
one minute you said i was not on the
floor the next minute you say
well yes there was a reason why i was
worried about the deficit
well but now we see that suburban more
moderate democrats
well those people were all duped it
didn't matter which man
won the policies and the direction we
would take would be the same
now we tried to warn you that biden as
moderate that whole brand was a total
charade
that he would always cave to the hard
left
and biden's anti-freedom anti-prosperity
plans
they have to be exposed and explained
now of course we already know that biden
is too weak to stop the riots
he's too weak to resist the radicals in
his own party
this is how nbc framed the 3.5
trillion dollar bernie loved budget
fiasco
that was just announced by the democrats
bernie sanders lost the presidency
but he's shaping the agenda now
progressives are
obviously thrilled about what biden
pelosi and schumer are giving them
and why wouldn't they be it's going to
go down as the most
anti-capitalist anti-growth anti-free
market piece of legislation
ever voted on in the history of america
take a look at this list amnesty for
illegals
and funding a civilian climate corps
this will be paid for in one of two ways
both with terrible outcomes for american
workers either biden's team
are going to have to borrow the money
which will make inflation even worse
than it is now
or what they're planning on is to jack
up taxes on wealthier americans and
businesses
and by the way they'll charge companies
penalties when they exceed
newly mandated carbon and methane output
levels
now this is literally insane
right now even after covid the us has
the strongest economy in the g7 and
these people
are working overtime to obliterate it
all
so i didn't go through the whole list
but all of the spending the medicare
expansion the child tax credit all the
stuff on the list
ends up being income redistribution
high taxes heavy regulations all of that
and the democrats
are fully embracing european style
socialism oh they love the family
medical leave that's all guaranteed
and just in time for german chancellor
progressive angela merkel
for her to come to town who's thrilled
about now having an american president
who lets her make all the decisions now
her uh ridiculous appearance today
of course loving uh being with joe biden
standing side by side
in the white house watch i'm delighted
to be here and now we have an
opportunity to talk more about our
bilateral
relationship about obviously always in
the context of european uh
matters we stand together and we'll
continue to stand together
to unite our efforts to up end and on
our global climate ambitions
that we have to up the ending
and why wouldn't europe be giddy about
biden there's no more dealing with the
u.s president who aggressively defends
our energy independence
the bottom line is clear today's
democrats have concluded
that american style free market
capitalism
is dangerous for the climate and for the
global order
so democrats see american prosperity and
wealth creation
as a threat not as an accomplishment
now obama's you didn't build that line
comes to mind
democrats and socialists abroad
tolerated the riots last summer because
they attacked the old order which they
think is basically greedy and racist
and that needs to be silenced and
replaced but by contrast these same
people
they're panicked now about the massive
protests in greece and france
crowds are opposing new coveted
restrictions and demanding freedom
as a lot of us would expect americans to
do as well
but democrats are giving the cuban
protesters a cold shoulder for the same
reason
those people are yearning for freedom
american style
at the same moment democrats are
trashing the country as racist
and trying to limit our freedom think
about that
increasing tax burdens on american
businesses
is a guaranteed way to hurt innovation
and productivity but biden is fine with
that
the promise of a better life via
government controls and income
redistribution
is always false it's all biden's got
it's one of the largest ever single tax
cuts for families with children
and it's a reflection of our belief that
the people of this country
who need a tax cut aren't the folks at
the top
but it's the people in the middle the
folks who are struggling
or just looking for a little bit of my
dad would say a little bit of breathing
room
a little bit of breathing room
now for almost 250 years our economy has
been breathing quite well
joe it thrived and it grew into a
juggernaut by recognizing a basic
principle
that the afghan economic system should
reward people for hard work
when you kill that incentive to work to
show up every day to create
you kill the very thing that drove the
prosperity that we enjoy today
the left has always resented middle
class workers living the american dream
they do things like drive pickup trucks
they own guns they have big families
they're proudly patriotic
so they intend to drive up the cost of
everything we buy and
everywhere we travel and then expect you
to thank them for it
after all they know how to spend your
money better than you do
the coming tax avalanche on businesses
will simply mean that
those businesses are going to pass along
their higher operating costs to
consumers
it's already happening when we're
effectively getting taxed on
everything a child care tax credit
that's not going to make much of a
difference
and speaking of the children universal
pre-k
is also in the bill i'm all for
educating our youth
but really educating them not
brainwashing toddlers with racist drivel
you think that can happen in preschool
guess again randy weingarten's union
has an anti-racist reading list that
includes picture books for
four-year-olds
here's what they want your kids learning
the cops
shot him because he was black cops stick
up for each other
and they don't like black men we can't
always count on cops to do what's right
the good news is that republicans even
the fools who support the phony
infrastructure bill
are united against this wild expansion
of government spending and controls
the last time republicans were this
united against a democrat cram down was
back in 2009
against obamacare and of course we all
remember what happened they went on to
flip congress in 2010 midterms
as a result and the democrats already
seem to know that that day is coming
which is why they're rushing right now
to get it all through
because it may be their last chance in a
while at least to fundamentally change
the american experience
republicans should be holding rallies
across the united states campaigning
against this nightmare and for a return
to sound
economic policy republicans should be
dogging so-called democrat moderates joe
manchin in west virginia
kirsten cinema and arizona and the bill
should be an
automatic no for any so-called moderate
of either party
and by the sounds of it though manson's
just waiting to have the deal
perhaps sweetened i'm concerned about
everything inflation i'm concerned about
the price i want to make sure that we're
paying for i want to make sure that we
have a competitive tax rate
i want to make sure that the climate
policies that there that they would like
to have
is an all-inclusive all the above energy
i want to make sure the united states of
america stays energy independent
he's going to totally vote for it that's
my prediction now west virginia voted
overwhelmingly for trump
not for soft-serve socialism but if
manchin votes for this that's exactly
what the voters of west virginia are
going to get
meantime there should be no more
bipartisan talks on anything
none zero it was so embarrassing to see
how romney and company were snookered in
that
so-called infrastructure deal they so
enjoyed the media adulation they got
that they
didn't see where this was going they
didn't see that they were being used
as props to set up the main act which is
unfolding right now
somewhere somewhere tonight bernie
sanders
is smiling that's all you need to know
and that's the angle